here's a story from the New York Times
Yemen's houi militia claims to have
launched an uh launched an attack on
Israel the Israeli military said it had
thwarted a batch of aerial threats but
did not say who was behind them Yemen
sui militia claimed an attempted attack
on Southern Israel in uh on Tuesday
saying it had launched a large batch of
ballistic and cruise missiles as well as
drones toward Israeli targets the
iran-backed militia carried out the
attempted assault in response to what it
called brutal Israeli American
aggression in Gaza the military
spokesman spokes smokesman Yaya serea
said on the social media platform acts
Mr s said the attack was the third
operation conducted by the houthis in
support of our persecuted Brothers in
Palestine and threatened further missile
and drone assaults the times could not
independently verify the claims on
Tuesday the isra Israeli military said
it a its aerial defense system had
intercepted a surfac to- surface missile
fired towards Israel from the area of
the Red Sea it said it has also
intercepted other aerial threats in the
area none of which entered Israeli
territory now now here's here's the big
concern I suppose if you're looking at
this through the lens of uh the Ben
chapiro perspective his view is that if
the US does not get involved and Stamp
Out aggression toward or assist in the
stamping out of aggression towards
Israel we are going to see an escalation
of these of assaults which results in
Israel taking the nuclear option perhaps
quite literally resulting in a World War
III scenario when uh basically the idea
is there's two ideas one in response to
a serious military threat that that
could end Israel Israel says fire
everything we've got the second scenario
similar is Israel facing its demise says
we're going to fire everything
everywhere and we're going to force the
intervention of other countries to stop
this conflict yeah and it's the exact
inverse of what Shiro saying the more we
do the more we intervene the more the
greater the threat of this turning into
a wider uh conflict more countries
that'll getting draw in you know you
have uh of course everything points back
to Iran here supposedly with Hezbollah
and now the houthis and so we're looking
at the possibility of drawing other uh
actors into this and the United States
is seemingly itching to attack Iran and
that's that's a problem so you know the
arming and funding of Israel is
outrageous this is drawing all these
actors out so we're actually our
interventions are causing this uh this
conflict to
escalate so the the I guess my question
is if the US does nothing do you think
these other countries these Iranian
backed militias in Iran do you think
they just ignore Israel or do you think
they attack Israel I mean if the US does
nothing but fund them to the tune of
$3.8 billion a year and now another 14
billion uh then of course there's going
to be our involvement we're already
implicated in the whole in the whole
conflict because of the arms and funding
we've been giving them over all this
time so yeah we need to re retrench we
need to pull back all of our funding and
yeah we would see that if we didn't
intervene in all these conflicts there
would be less conflict in the world and
especially the Middle East do you think
that if the United States were not
giving uh funding giving weapons and
essentially essentially it's probably
just giving weapons that the US pays uh
weapon manufacturers for but if the US
were not and the Israelis were just
buying weapons from us manufacturers do
you think that the the houthis and Iran
would look at it any differently because
in my opinion I don't think that the
people the countries and and states that
don't like Israel would see a
distinction even if we weren't giving it
away if we were like look us firms are
allowed to sell you like Ron and Boeing
sell you weapons but we're not paying
for it I don't really strongly believe
that the the Iranians are going to
consider that a they'll call it a
difference without a distinction well I
don't know we we we're giving them the
money and then they buy the arms that's
how it works 3.8 billion a year so I
think that you know if if I don't think
first of all Israel would be able to
afford as much arms if it weren't for
these outlandish uh grants every year
and uh then add 14 billion on top of it
and you've got the United States totally
implicated so I mean I don't see how uh
that helps anything at all and so yeah
if they were just buying their arms and
and largely from the United States
perhaps those countries would still
consider the us implicated but there's
no doubt that our you know that we're
fully involved in this because of that
and right now us rockets and bombs are
falling on children in Palestine this is
an outrage and this is should be
something that we completely oppose uh
it has no we have no business doing this
and it's I think it's blood on our hands
frankly I agree the US shouldn't fund it
but I I just am not I'm not convinced
that other countries would see a
distinction I let's try it for once we
hav love it we haven't tried this ever
you know so why why don't we give it a
try 100% 100% I'm I'm not I'm not trying
to push back against the idea I think we
tried it during the uh the barbery
wars the US the US was kind of like hey
can we not go to war with you guys like
what's going on and then they were like
n we're going to keep stealing burn
there was no Israel back then but yeah
no but my point is like it was only the
founding fathers who are like the United
States will not be involved in these
foreign conflicts and then you get to
you know late 1800s early 1900s and the
politicians then are like I think the US
should be involved in foreign affairs
and just start setting up military
conquests why not and there you have it
and now we have 800 bases around the
world oh yeah yeah yeah and one in
Israel by the way apparently there's a
secret base in is Israel right now it's
called 152 it's this very uh you know
nondescript name and that we're actually
we have forces located in there they're
saying it's just uh living
accommodations but it it has uh US
forces in it uh this has been revealed
so site 512 is that yes that's it yeah
so we have this is a this is The
Intercept right us quietly expand secret
military base in Israel government
documents pointed construction at a
classified US base offer rare hints
about little noted US military presence
near Gaza and there was there was some
reporting hard to know what's true
claiming that US forces were actually in
Gaza during The Invasion and may be
there now and uh perhaps it's very hard
to tell I mean all this is kept secret
these 2,000 troops that were sent over
they're they're sent to an undisclosed
location we don't know where they are
the defense department will not say
where they are so I mean for for certain
military reasons that makes sense but we
we still don't know they may be in
Israel what what I'm not familiar with
the with the The Troop deployment I know
that there's two Marine Expeditionary
units that are with the carrier groups
but I don't know about yeah there's uh
2,000 troops that been sent over 2,000
in you know I don't know if they're in
infantry or Marines or what whatever
they are they're there and in the region
but they won't tell us where they are in
the region I bet they're in Iraq and
then of course we have two aircraft
carriers in the uh in the Mediterranean
and uh you know we have tons of arms
just loaded around so I think they're
trying to bait the us into a conflict if
something gets struck we're going to go
in oh yeah well now with the US hostages
you you have the argument that oh the
reason we have Delta Forces on the
ground yeah is because of the hostages
the the presence of 200 US troops in
Iraq and another 900 in eastern Syria
both on missions against the Islamic
State this
is uh I'm not looking Trump tried
bringing them back yeah but don't you
think that um our what what are your
thoughts on this I mean a lot of people
say that uh if the US is not if the US
just retracts everything China just
sweeps in I don't agree I mean they they
moved into uh Afghanistan well they're I
mean you know the thing is we're in
terms of China what we're doing is
provoking them as well because we're
talking about now sending uh military
aid to Taiwan this is an utter
provocation so we're drawing China into
conflict seemingly on purpose and I
don't think China is going to try uh
take first of all they don't have the
military power to do it they do not have
the military power to take over the
United States or invade us or anything
like that no but I mean they'll start
they'll they'll grow that power they'll
move into Central America there's
already concerns they they're going to
try and make a move they were trying to
build the Nicaraguan Canal to gain
control or or at least compete with the
Panama Canal people were uh there's a
rumor about their them trying to gain
control of the Panama Canal they'll uh
they're going to they're already moving
into Africa and South America yeah mean
this these are not military conquest
though and no it's more like you know
the West uses the IMF it's the Belton
Road initiative and uh this is how
they're growing their soft power and you
know frankly we should open up trade
with China we we are now embargoing
their uh chips we refuse to send certain
chips to China what's this going to do
this is already hurting our economy and
what it'll do for them is they'll just
go elsewhere for these chips uh they'll
make them themselves or get get them
else we are not sending them chips is
what you're saying we refuse to send
them certain chips yeah there's a
there's a concern though that they're
reverse engineering a lot of our
intellectual property a lot of our
technology but they're also sending us
compromised electronics that was a big
story a few years ago where they're like
your toaster could be broadcasting a
signal and you wouldn't know and it's
stealing your information I I don't
think China is our real our real uh
threat the number one primary enemy
frankly who is the state our government
our government our government well
elaborate why I mean our government has
look who has who's responsible for more
deaths of Americans than our government
uh we have sent more people over to die
than any country is killed so we're
actually Prov provoking other countries
we're entering in all these military
Expeditions and in that way the state
itself is more responsible for us deaths
than China Iran uh Russia uh or uh North
Korea combined you know I thought about
this and I was thinking that it it seems
like there's an occup Force that's been
controlling this country because the
American people don't want war right
they never want war almost never and yet
here we are consistently going into Wars
without having declared war on anybody
and then I think no it's probably better
to just say we were sold out by our
politicians who continue to sell us out
so it's not so much that we're occupied
it's that uh we have a fractured U uh
government and a and and corrupt
politicians everyone agrees with well I
don't know how fractured is because when
it comes to war and Military uh
Expeditions and and foreign policy this
is a unip party they're not even there's
no distance between these people it does
seem to be like the only time they ever
actually agree on anything is when it's
going to war in other countries have
there been polls done recently about
what the American public's thoughts are
on war right now given obviously we know
what the American people think of war in
Ukraine but have there been studies or
any type of polls that have been done
talking about what they think about
military intervention in Israel
interestingly there was a pull down on
Biden's approvability rating which fell
by 11% uh among Democrats so that's a
good sign so it went from 86 to 75% and
for uh Arab Americans it fell like uh
from like 58 to 177% in in a matter of
weeks so uh interestingly there is a
divide in the U in the population in
terms of support for Biden uh because
you know I mean the Le a lot of the left
doesn't want this uh conflict now they
are hypocrites because they were fully
in support of the Ukraine war and the
right is also hypocritical because now
they're in support of this war in Israel
but they weren't in support of the war
in Ukraine so and also in hindsight they
opposed the rocky War isn't that
convenient thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net hanging out and we'll see
you all next
time